de la reine pour toujours le royaume a
peur c'est la Nathan c'est un monstre
c'est l'homme qui me faut
je m'appelle Nicolas votre fidèle à
colite c'est avec vous j'ai pas besoin
de la coller tous les méchants des
acolytes je suis pas méchant d'accord
le vrai méchant court toujours et j'ai
besoin à tête pour la rareté
si j'étais vous je partirai en courant
je sais pas quoi je sais pas quoi je
sais pas quoi et à la fin on gagne
c'est moi
vous avez été trahi par une personne de
confiance et une fois qu'on vous colle
l'étiquette de méchante et depuis la
changer
tu crois qu'il nous avait
oui
parfois le monde vous maltraite
mais ensemble on peut lui rendre compte
officiel pour toujours on revient pas en
arrière
[Musique]
tu peux seulement rester toi-même ça
veut dire quoi ça
[Musique]